alrighty here we are i'm about to give
you everything you need to know about
the amy coney barrett supreme court
hearings in 10 minutes or less sponsored
by our friends over
at raycon so who is amy coney bear first
of all she's 48 years old which means
that presumably she will serve on the
supreme court for decades to come
she attended notre dame law school which
is not one of the ivy leagues so she
would be
i think the only justice on the supreme
court who didn't go to an ivy league
school
she clerked for justice antonin scalia
she was appointed by chief justice john
roberts in 2010 to serve on the advisory
committee for the federal rules of
appellate procedure she's obviously
quite brilliant she was nominated for
the seventh circuit court of appeals in
by president trump during that
nomination process dianne feinstein the
senator from california
suggested that her religious viewpoints
would actually bias her legal viewpoints
because of course she's a religious
catholic here was senator feinstein at
the time suggesting that the doctrine
lived loudly with an amy coney barrett
when you read your speeches
the conclusion one draws
is that the dogma lives
loudly within you amy coney barrett sort
of became a conservative star
at that point she was confirmed by the
senate 55 to 43 for the seventh circuit
court of appeals three democrats voted
for her
she was considered for justice
kavanaugh's seat and of course justice
kavanaugh filled that one then she was
chosen by president trump to replace
ruth bader ginsburg she's been married
for over 20 years she has seven children
two of whom are adopted from haiti her
youngest biological child
does have down syndrome she's a
practicing catholic and she famously
served as a women's leader
in an ecumenical community called people
of praise which drove the media
up a wall because she was a handmaid
because the media have never met a
catholic and they have never read the
new testament so they don't understand
that a handmaid is not from the margaret
atwood novel but actually just
a description of all humans from the new
testament during the hearings
amy coney barrett spotlighted the fact
that she is deeply invested in her
family and doesn't see her job as the be
all end-all
as i said when i was nominated to serve
as a justice
i'm used to being in a group of nine my
family
nothing is more important to me and i am
very proud to have them behind me
as you can see she's quite poised and
she's excellent on camera what really
makes amy coney bear appealing to
conservatives and people who care about
the constitution
is that she truly does understand the
role of a court now to understand the
conflict here you have to understand
that for folks on the right
they typically understand the role of
the court to be what the role of the
court was at the founding
namely not a super legislature not a
group of people who get to
insert their own morality into the
constitution of the united states the
role of the judiciary is instead
to interpret the law as written if you
want to make a political change you do
that in the political branches namely
through the legislature or through the
executive
but the unelected branch of government
the judiciary is just there to ensure
that the law as it is written
is actually applied that's what a judge
is there to do amy coney barrett
understands this extremely well
folks on the left do not they believe
that courts are there to cram down their
policy priorities
courts are there to be just another tool
in their arsenal courts are there
to enshrine abortion even though the
constitution says nothing about it
courts are there to enshrine
same-sex marriage in the constitution
even though the supreme court has
nothing to say on that issue
in terms of the constitution supreme
court is there to ensure that every
policy priority
beloved by democrats is enshrined into
law the constitution
is merely a bit of poetry that you kind
of use in order to cram down your
particular point of view amy coney
barrett
disagrees with that general prescription
when it comes to law here was amy coney
barrett saying
courts are not designed to do the
quote-unquote moral thing courts are
designed to interpret the law
courts are not designed to solve every
problem or right every wrong in our
public life
the policy decisions and value judgments
of government
must be made by the political branches
elected by and accountable to the people
the public should not expect courts to
do so and courts
should not try this is obviously true
this was the founding structure
alexander hamilton famously wrote in
federalist 78 that the courts would be
the least dangerous branch because they
had neither force
nor will meaning that their job was not
to will certain things into existence
and they didn't have the power to
even effectuate their own decision
making amy queen barrett suggested that
a judge imposing politics
as opposed to just interpreting the law
that would cut directly against
democracy
part of the rationale for courts
adhering to the rule
of law and for judges taking great care
to avoid imposing their policy
preferences is that it's inconsistent
with democracy
nobody wants to live in accord with the
law of amy i'm sure
my children don't even want to do that
obviously she is correct about this so
what is her interpretive approach her
approach is how you read any law
namely that she says it is important to
adhere to the text as written not as i
wish it were but just
as it is i don't get to make up what the
law is here she was explaining
more than the style of his writing
though it was the content of justice
scalia's reasoning that shaped me
his judicial philosophy was
straightforward
a judge must apply the law as it is
written
not as she wishes it were that of course
is exactly right originalism is just the
basic philosophy that when you read a
piece of text it means what it says you
don't get to just interpret it randomly
dan rather of course you know that
newsman that we were all supposed to
trust he doesn't understand anything
because he's an idiot so instead he
suggested
that being an originalist means
rejecting pretty much everything he says
if you want to be an originalist in law
maybe you should go all the way
cooking on a hearth leeches for medicine
an old mule for transportation or maybe
you can recognize
that the world changes the world does
change the job of a judge
is to make sure that the text that they
are reading is applied
to the principles of the modern world
that is the job of a judge
nobody is suggesting that if you're an
originalist this means that you should
be living without a toilet
that's ridiculous the fact that this
was ever trusted as a newsman
honestly it's beyond reason all right
stop the clock because i have to talk
about something different
these the everyday e25 raycon earbuds
these are my favorite wireless earbuds
on the market now
i may have little in common with cardi b
aside from the fact that we are both
platinum
award-winning rap artists but one thing
we definitely have in common
are these we both use these raycons
raycon offers their wireless earbuds in
a range of magical colors
and patterns they're super comfortable
they come with a variety of fit options
the compact carrying case can charge
your buds
four times on a single charge unlike
some of your other wireless options
raycon earbuds they're stylish and
discreet no tingling wires
no stems they are great for video chats
one of the things that i love about
raycon is the fact
that you can actually customize the fit
to your ears so they are not going to
fall out of your ears like the one size
fits all version
they sound just as amazing as other top
audio brands you know and they're going
to cost you about half the price
raycons they're great for working from
home working out listening to music
go check them out right now and you will
receive
a special deal they're every day 25 year
but the best model yet six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth daring more
bass a more compact design that gives
you that nice noise isolating fit click
the link in the description
below to get 15 off your order right now
and get yourself a pair of these babies
these raycons alrighty let's get back
into it
so acb during the hearing she avoided a
lot of questions from democrats about
exactly how this would play out
in terms of how she would rule the
reason being there was something called
the ginsburg rule it was established as
the name suggests
during the ruth bader ginsburg hearings
because it turns out ruth bader ginsburg
was a partisan democrat she worked for
the aclu and democrats led by joe biden
said she doesn't have to answer any
questions
about how she's going to rule on cases
and everybody went okay and then they
approved her 93-nothing
acb followed the ginsburg rule to the
letter here she was doing that
i'm going to invoke justice kagan's
description which i think is
perfectly put when she was in her
confirmation hearing she said
that she was not going to grade
precedent or give it a thumbs up or a
thumbs down
if i express a view on a precedent one
way or another whether i say i love it
or i hate it
it signals to litigants then i might
tilt one way or another in
a pending case okay because democrats
were not able to bully or cudgel
out of her all of the rulings that they
wanted
instead they just started asking her
unbelievably stupid questions so this
was really the theme
of the entire thing they asked her many
many stupid questions so for example
cory booker just asked her straight out
if she was a white supremacist really to
hit trump
but because cory booker is a dummy i
want to just ask you very simply i
imagine you'll give me a very short
resolute answer
um but you condemn white supremacy
correct
yes the look on her face says it all the
look on her face says it all maisie
hirono
the idiot senator from hawaii she asked
if amy coney barrett was a sexual
predator
since you became a legal adult have you
ever made
unwanted requests for sexual favors or
committed any verbal
or physical harassment or assault over
sexual nature
no senator hirono have you ever faced
discipline
or entered into a settlement related to
this kind of conduct
no senator one of the things that's so
great about amy coney berry is she's
able to keep a straight face no matter
what idiocy is being
thrown at her maisie hirono finally came
up with a brick to hit
amy coney barrel with she claimed that
because amy coney bear had used the
phrase sexual preference a phrase used
by people ranging from
joe biden to the advocate magazine this
meant that actually amy coney barrett
hates gay people here is mazie hirono
claiming a offense over a completely
non-offensive term or a term that became
offensive within the last 32 seconds
not once but twice you use the term
sexual preference to describe those in
the lgbtq
community and let me make clear sexual
preference is an offensive and outdated
term
it is used by anti-lgbtq activists
to suggest that sexual orientation is a
choice
it was a slur a pathetic slur by maisie
hirono an idiot against amy coney
barrett
naturally webster's dictionary
immediately redefined the term
preference to suggest that it was
offensive because we now live in an
orwellian world bottom line is this
though
they could not stop amy coney barrett
during the actual hearing when they
asked her any sort of legal questions
she ran circles around them
leading to this viral moment in which
john cornyn of texas asked her to show
her notes
can you hold up what you've been
referring to and answering our questions
is there anything on it uh that
letterhead that says united states
senate
so bottom line is this thing moved
through the judiciary committee on a
straight party line vote it will come to
the senate next week
and amy coney bear will be confirmed
sometime next week and before
the election there you have it the
entire amy coney barrett hearing in 10
minutes
or less hope you enjoyed we'll see you
here next time and thanks to our
sponsors over at raycon
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content